sagement ils savent à coach j'étais
juste une petite douleur passagère
selimi vit dans l'ombre de son frère
parce que son grand frère elle a réussi
ses deux modèles de de tout le monde
dans le centre tout le monde le connaît
réservé à qui vous entraîne le
personnage de céline finalement c'est un
petit peu l'antithèse du personnage de
jb lui ivan ils osent tout il est très
fier de lui pas ce qui se passait là je
sens que c'est notre année à tous les
deux selim c'est un peu le dragueur mecs
qui courent après les filles quelle
impression qui peut tout les avoir comme
ça qu'on demande aujourd'hui ses limites
bien lourd en technique darragi les
chromes il a aucune honte en fait sa
clémence qu'il a aucune continue on va
vers une me fit son film disque
c'est pourquoi
le décrirais comme un garçon fragile
n'est pas bien dans sa tête et le coach
il est il est là pour remettre remettre
sur le droit chemin et lui dire qu'il
faut travailler
s'il est dansante c'est qu'il est mais
je me tâte choisie ait en pagaille
candeloro